be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back I say welcome back welcome
to top five Tuesday's a weekly series
where we count down the top 5 characters
teams and concepts from across the comic
book industry and this week we're going
to be counting down the top 5 most
powerful items in the Marvel Universe
the so number 5 on our list comes in the
form of the ultimate nullifier initially
appearing and Fantastic Four number 50
as part of the Galactus trilogy the
ultimate nullifier was located by Johnny
Storm at the request of a watching The
Watcher as the only known method of
forcing Galactus away from the planet
Earth while the history of the artifact
is largely unknown the precious little
information that we have is smattered
about the Marvel Universe in bits and
pieces while rarely ever used in the
Marvel comics the ultimate nullifier
seems to have been created by Colitis
himself and its power is relative to
those who were wielding it for example
in the original cent event one of the
mindless ones a member of a race of
beings from another dimension that has
incredible strength but doesn't have any
real thinking power basically uses the
ultimate nullifier to destroy itself and
when it does it creates what's
equivalent to a nuclear explosion
however in Fantastic Four vol 3
issue number 50 Abraxas who is the
amalgamation of evil that arose when
Galactus of the main Marvel Universe was
destroyed this version this character
Abraxas was able to use the ultimate
nullifier to wipe out entire realities
and actually create new realities and so
because the ultimate nullifier has the
potential to eliminate realities
entirely what we know is the ultimate
nullifier is kept under lock and key at
virtually all times because it's never
used it's usually kept within the safe
confines of the watchtower of who
watching The Watcher or else sometimes
it's found within the ship of the latus
himself but regardless of the
circumstances the ultimate nullifier is
one of the last-ditch effort kind of
weapons that various superheroes or even
villains can use if the need arises for
it so coming in at number 4 on our list
is the Cosmic Cube initially appearing
in tales of suspense number 17
in 1966 but achieving mainstream
popularity with the Cosmic Cube event
coinciding with the first appearance of
Thanos the Cosmic Cube is the result of
energy stored in the negative zone by
the beyonders being harnessed into a
cube form and it's actually subject to
the will of its user what I mean here is
that during the Cosmic Cube event where
Thanos was able to capture the Cosmic
Cube and use it it was actually
established as being able to fulfill the
heart's desires of the wielder which
basically allowed fan OHS to become one
with the universe itself however the
cube was presumably drained of all of
its power and ultimately it was
destroyed by Marvel of the Kree and so
this resulted in a deep Howard Thanos
just kind of being stranded and stuck
out in space in addition to this while
the various cosmic cubes have appeared
over the course of the Marvel Universe
in its continuity and Fantastic Four
issue number 319 it was revealed that
over time the cosmic cubes will actually
evolve into sentient beings of immense
power although we don't really know what
these beings do or where they go once
they reach their true potential a
surrounding on our list at the number 3
spot is the cosmic control rod initially
appearing in Fantastic Four annual issue
number six in 1968 the cosmic control
rod is an artifact of incredible power
that's actually capable of manipulating
the molecular structure of all matter in
any given universe that happens to be in
with its introduction into Marvel Comics
as a means to save Susan storm during
the birthing process of Franklin
Richards the cosmic control rod was
actually stolen by Reed Richards Johnny
Storm and Ben Grimm the thing from the
villain Annihilus in the negative zone
the result was that Reed's use of the
cosmic control rod not only allowed
Susan storm to survive and give birth to
Franklin Richards
but also seems to be the reason why
Franklin Richards has such vast powers
that allow him to warp all of reality
there so coming in at number 2 on our
list is none other than the fan favorite
the Infinity Gauntlet making its first
appearance during the Infinity Gauntlet
event itself the gauntlet is actually
the glove of Thanos with five infinity
gems B
position on each knuckle and with the
six Jim being positioned on the back of
the hand due to the vast power of the
Infinity stones and their ability to
allow its user to manipulate all facets
of the universe Thanos was able to use
the Infinity Gauntlet to eliminate half
the life in the universe by snapping his
fingers defeat an entire contingent of
the universe's most powerful heroes and
even replaced the cosmic entity eternity
at the top of the pantheon of the Marvel
mainstream earth-616 universe the power
of the Infinity Gauntlet was so great in
fact that following the Infinity
Gauntlet of then the Living Tribunal who
exists to maintain balance in all
realities ordered the Infinity Gauntlet
to be dispersed and to never again be
assembled except for times of extreme
need and so with the Infinity Gauntlet
and its vast power being ranked at
number 2 on our list the question
becomes what's number one well for me
the most powerful item in the Marvel
Universe actually comes in the form of
the heart of the universe itself during
the events of Marvel the end Thanos was
successfully able to gain absolute power
in the Marvel Universe once again as it
was described by Thanos or the Infinity
Gauntlet allows its wielder to
manipulate the concepts of the universe
for lack of a better word the heart
actually allows us wielder to become one
with everyone and everything in the
universe and so after realizing that a
fault existed which would result in the
destruction of this universe Thanos uses
the heart to eliminate all life and even
destroy the universe in its entirety
however when Adam warlock appears before
Thanos having existed outside of the
main universe Adam warlock convinces
Thanos to set everything back to normal
which he does this is the power of the
heart of the universe Thanos wasn't
defeated he simply just kind of gave up
and just set everything back well that
being said we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later peace
[Music]